ready one two three
let's serve up some news sunny side up
oh it's about to get so real because the
material girl aha madonna
she still likes to burn that midnight
oil rolling stone reports that madonna
loves to stay up late her bedtime these
days is 4 00 a.m wow and she is using
some of that time to work on the script
for her upcoming biopic
um first of all
literally this this this makes me cagey
even talking about a four a.m bedtime so
you love madonna right i am a big
madonna fan yes yes i'm looking forward
to whatever her biopic turns out to be
and stuff but i think she should get
some more sleep i think i'm worried
about that oh look at you guys together
look there's looking that's you and
that's madonna right there
what does madonna say to you yeah what
is she saying to you right now
i don't i don't know i mean you don't
remember
she was saying very important things at
the time i i don't recall
the kardashian sisters kim and courtney
took a trip to knott's berry farm this
weekend and this is an exclusive from
people.com they report snl's pete
davidson joined them and was spotted on
a roller coaster holding camps with kim
k and they say reportedly they're just
friends oh they're just
friends their hands are you know i'm not
good with the left yeah you're not good
[Applause]
and there's a difference because if you
and i are on a roller coaster i would
hold your hand if you were scared but i
don't know that we would intertwine if
you know what i mean
guess who just joined instagram are you
ready for this uh-huh
okay because he's one of the most
influential rappers in history he just
got inducted into the rock of rural hall
and fame this weekend he's a billionaire
he's a game changer it's jay-z welcome
people report
um that jay almost got two million
followers instantaneously
um and he follows just one account can
you guess what that one account is
come on right
the first post that he did
was the harder they fall
which is a new netflix movie that he
co-produced and wrote music for it's a
western starring regina king and idris
elba oh we'll all be there for that oh
yeah hello we told you that kim
kardashian and pete davidson they're
just friends right well now drew page
six reports they were spotted again
i know i'm obsessed they were seen
separately at the manhattan club zero
bond and then the night before that they
shared a private rooftop dinner
in staten island where p is from the
king of staten island yes pete got kim
kardashian to go to staten island
and we do hear that he pete called and
reserved the whole rooftop which you
don't do for someone who's just a friend
am i right or am i right am i right i've
been on the other side of it there's
nothing worse than when you're trying to
get to know someone and everyone else is
making it their business so
i have to apologize that i'm horrified
and i have get why everybody's excited
about it yeah i simultaneously want to
keep my distance and be respectful and
sorry
not sorry for many people over the last
year and a half the pandemic allowed for
a time to rethink our lives and careers
and as a result
tons of people are making big changes
and cbs news reports that the great
resignation is happening across america
and
four million people quit in july alone
wow
and some young people have actually
headed towards a farm
um some college grads say that the more
work that they do on the farm the more
meaningful that they feel their lives
have become
ross thoughts well i'm not moving to a
farm um
but i do think you know the real the
real question here is in this time it
has been so unprecedented have we all
taken a chance to look and thought think
to ourselves what do i really want for
me was about my health you know i i
think i got my body together a little
bit during this time because it was what
do i want i want to be here i want to be
here and that's the decision i made so i
think anyone watching or reading this
article we're talking about should ask
them that question what do we we want if
anything came out of this time it was a
pause on the world to focus on ourselves
again so i love that people are doing
this i won't be on the farm but
congratulations to you
[Music]